taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man
folks it's taste buds podcast
how you doing
you jumped right into that and then uh i
don't know it's just funny
you're just like how you doing do you
enjoy it i did good good i like i like
when you take the reins in the beginning
you you do the equivalent of that yeah
if the show was a horse who takes the
reigns on uh hey babe usually
we start off singing a
song in unison okay yes
that we just i don't know how it started
actually i think i was like hey
babe hey
babe and then we just sang it one day
and then the next time we just added it
so that's how it happens i sang a song
when i did it
i gotta play
a message that you left me
i gotta find it maybe i could find it
and play it when you send me a song you
like when i wasn't feeling well
and you left me a message on my phone
that was like my sweet boy
how are you feeling my sweet boy i was
crying laughing with him can i find it
and play it good yeah okay yeah please
let's see let's see
sal and i trade audio messages a lot we
talked about that on the show before but
you save all of them which i do not do
and now i'm regretting that i haven't
done that yeah i don't say yeah now
because i have it on default that they
say because otherwise you have to wait
and hit keep otherwise they leave after
two minutes all right i'm going to send
the default said it didn't know you
could do that i didn't know either until
i found out
oh okay okay let's see if i could find
now we both no okay i came home around
this time so let me see
and i hope this helps as you lay your
head on your pillow put the phone next
to your ear
sleep sleep my baby
feverish baby
sleep sleep my baby
i love you
[Laughter]
take
your medicine
drink the coughs here up
sleep sleep my baby
[Music]
yeah when i when i was recording that i
was like i was laughing because i was
like this sounds like when a man sings
before he murders you yeah yeah it's
like very like silence of the land
you're like take your medicines yeah
drink the cough syrup it doesn't really
fly i love you
we gotta get those lyrics on the back of
a shirt
we gotta get those lyrics
what if next week
the intro is not the taste buds
it's not the taste buds at all but it's
just derosa
being like sleep my baby
i love you we should make that we should
make that the outro music every week we
should publish it to spotify as its own
song it's just a single oh can we do
that
oh okay all right i'll send it to you
cut out the beginning part of the
message and just have his night time and
this way anyone can co-op that and play
that for their child when they're not
feeling well yeah and then people can
remix it because it's just
sounds of derozan it's just acapella
people can do whatever they want with it
that'd be fun man let's do that that's
what you sound like like what someone
would sing to their child when they were
like like in m night shyamalan's the
village yeah you know what i mean like
you have your medicines
oh it's fun stuff it's fun stuff i love
it i love it that's fun all right pimp's
gonna cut that up and then we'll put it
out
speaking of fun fun rhymes with bun
bun
like a cinnabon cinnabon like a cinnabon
to help today's today in my opinion
we might have alienated a few people
because these stores are
they're they're very popular around
they're not everywhere but they're in
most places at least here in the states
but we've got a hell of a mall match up
today the cinnabon versus annie anne's
oh i mean this is oh you're gonna need
to keep that a page of me when i get to
it pimpy how did we not think of this
one earlier this is nice because it's
branding which i like it's brand names
going against each other if you aren't
familiar with either of them or you are
overseas and they are unavailable simply
substitute andy anne's pretzels for a
hot pretzel
uh but it's more than that because they
have all different colors flavors and
dips colors
well they do actually have different
colors there's a jalapeno pretzel
there's a sour cream and onion pretzel
uh which is bright white there's a
pepperoni one with red dots on it
because now i'm going to want this
see this just i can't just look i'm from
philly and i love a soft pretzel these
disgust me looking at them not true at
all
and cinnabon is a cinnamon roll
essentially a cinnamon bun or cinnamon
roll so substitute that although i'm
sure cinnabon is the ultimate
the elevated of the center they also
have churros cinnamon sticks uh you know
all different types look at this dude
they got a so
they have a bowl
just called center of the roll where
they take all the outside part out and
just put the middle part it's good i
recently had my first cinnabon in my
life by the way
it's on hey believe it or not it's
heavenly dude chris stopped and got one
on the way here because i never tried
when i tried it and it is very good i
will tell you
it is gooey and sticky and delicious but
it is dense it is heavy it is over the
top it's a bit too much and my favorite
part of the whole thing is actually the
icing
which really is is like really five
percent of the cinnabon which is why uh
cinnabon very early on and stated the
extra icing policy what is that yes for
extra icing and they give you a cup
extra cup of it i know a lot of people
that do that that's true yeah
yeah i've never heard of that joe look
at me in the face you've never been to a
cinnabon i never have but i've never
heard anyone speak about that yeah you
that's don't mean to give you actually
that's our home run policy they'll
gladly give you a little extra frosting
well you don't believe hey
siri cinnabon near me
put it to the mic call
cinnabon
babe cinnabon
hello serious cinnabon
cinnabon call them
you got to start over [ __ ] hey siri
call cinnabon
you know if apple if you're watching and
we know that you are do something about
siri because alexa's whooping her high
yeah i know alexa is real good
calling cinnabon
you're telling me there's a policy that
they instated where you say i want more
icing now and they hand it to you i want
extra icing with my cinnamon they give
you a little cup do they charge you
no i don't think so purchasing extra
icing is not what you said you said i
said that they're an extra
they're
quite familiar with people wanting extra
icing
hey can i ask you a question about the
cinnabon
um
someone told me and i don't know if it's
true cause they were gonna come by there
if you want extra icing uh if someone
wants extra icing do you guys provide
that as a side just free of charge in a
cup or do you have to pay extra for the
extra icing
you have to pay extra for the frosting
uh how much is that an extra side of
frosting
99
okay but there is no policy made by
cinnabon corporate wherein you want
extra icing and you say please give me
extra icing and you guys give them a
free side of icing in a cup
uh
i don't know what you're saying yeah
nobody does thank you so much sir
i never said they just give you free
icing i said they have a policy where
they're in the practice of giving extra
icing when you ask for it which he just
denied
i it's like kind of like when you get
extra sauce for your nuggets they charge
you but they know that it's a thing
it's like extra cheese like it's a
feature i should have said feature sorry
ordering more of what they sell is not a
feature in my eyes
you said there was a policy that made me
i think it was a feature cinnabon brass
got together and said you know what as a
lifestyle choice we're going to have a
thing where people know if they want
extra icing
they get it on the good news for you
babe i ain't been in a cinnabon in years
why would my friends talking about
cinnabon corporate policy then i didn't
talk about corporate policy i'm telling
you i used to go to the cinnabon in the
king of pressure plaza with my friend
bill and he would ask for extra icing
and they'd always give him a little cup
of it that's all i know okay they never
argued they never scoffed they seemed
like man's talking 99 cents plus state
and local tax i mean i look in my book
99 cents for a an extra cup of delicious
icing i mean what are you complaining
about here okay you know you go it's
like it's like i just feel like i poked
a hole let's put it this way a place
does it wendy's doesn't have add bacon
on the menu for no reason it's because
they know some people want that bacon
cinnabon knows some people want more
icing so they've got it on the menu 99
cents an extra thing of icing all right
i think it's there i called it a policy
i used the wrong term and i admit that
okay
well look cinnabon tell you what you
think you're getting these sauces for
free and annie anne's no but i didn't
say that i didn't say i never said
anyone's menu folks let's start with the
dips you got a honey mustard by the way
the hot pretzel in and of itself is a
powerhouse food that fills you up it's
always good i love a sauce i love
dipping mustard in it i love a big
bavarian german pretzel at a place like
that i love a ball game pretzel i love
it a city hot pretzel from the corner
from the dirty water dog guy there
you'll you'll be hard-pressed to find
people that don't really hold up a soft
press soft hot pretzel that being said
who is innovating this who is coming up
with better taste profiles who is coming
up and and blowing the doors open in the
soft hot pretzel world annie has been
around since 1988 with 1500 locations
you got your standard mustard dip that's
a a layup with all pretzels they got the
honey mustard they got the cream cheese
dip they have a sweet glaze dip the same
sweet glaze that goes on cinnabons
it's a hundred percent buddy a hundred
percent that's the same owner
it's the same exact concept it's creamy
uh white sweet
icing i can't have it all right
let me get this straight you're gonna
nail me to the wall on cinnabun's 99
cent extra frosting policy you got the
audacity to after you had said about one
time to tell me that annie hands is the
same exact yes
where is the audacity it's the same
thing i'm just getting this i'm just
stating a fact it might be similar how
about the hot salsa cheese dip that's
not salsa or cheese it's hot salsa
cheese i'm gonna go down how about a
caramel dip i'm gonna go down this list
no no go back pam
caramel dip who cares cheese dip looks
gross
salsa cheese dip disgusting for a
pretzel you know your hair light cream
cheese dip doesn't go with a pretzel
marinara dip no thank you sweet glazed
dip i could see it and maybe a honey
mustard the marinara you know the only
one i'll give you the one you claimed
isn't even on there what mustard
honey mustard there's no regular mustard
dip on there that's cause they're not
gonna put mustard as a as a dip why
because it's just a condiment no it's
not how dare you it's not just a
condiment baby girl you don't think
they're gonna give you a mustard yes i'm
not seeing a brown mustard dip which is
what i would want to put my soft pretzel
into and i'm arguing i'm arguing the
annie anne's pretzel so i won't jump
into the rest of their menu where they
wrap and all be frank in their delicious
pretzel bun and they have it with
jalapeno and cheese i won't even get
into that i mean this stuff i'm getting
a stomachache just looking at this no
way dude
folks if it's fresh it's hello fresh
what is hellofresh with hellofresh you
get
fresh
pre-measured ingredients mouth watering
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
door skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable that's why it's
america's number one meal kit and why
wouldn't it be with their family
friendly menu and a big win for the back
to school season by the way parents out
there this makes it a real easy and
delicious way for you to cook some great
recipes for the families for drama-free
dinners you know we know if you're at
the table hello fresh over 50 menu and
market items to choose from every single
week vegetarian meals calorie smart
options extra special gourmet options is
something for everyone to enjoy with
recipes designed and tested by
professional chefs and nutritional
experts to ensure deliciousness and
simplicity and let's talk value
hellofresh is over 30 cheaper than
shopping at the grocery store they've
got pre-portioned ingredients to ensure
you won't spend money on excess food
that ends up going in the trash people i
don't know what the problem is here it
comes to your door it's cheaper than
going to the store and you don't have to
think i mean this this is the only way
i'll cook actually i don't need i need
to be given a structure and i also can i
just say something i also really find it
pleasant
to cook with other people and make it a
social event open up a glass of wine and
have an experience while you make your
meal it makes you enjoy the meal more
and i don't have that experience when i
don't use hellofr i agree hellofresh.com
tastebuds14 that's
hellofresh.com
tastebuds14 and use the code tastebuds14
to get 14 free meals including shipping
that is hellofresh.com tastebuds14 and
use the code tastebuds14 to get 14 free
meals including shipping hello
hellofresh america's number one meal kit
summertime's a time to travel and some
some of you might be lucky enough to be
traveling abroad and guess what maybe
you want to learn a language before you
get to your destination and that's where
babel comes in the number one selling
language learning app from ordering in
restaurants or asking for directions to
gaining a deeper knowledge or
understanding of a culture babel's there
for you to make the whole process of
learning that new language addictively
fun and easy that is the part it's an
app and and they have 15 minute lessons
and it's not like when we took language
in like high school and school where
it's like drilling you they make it fun
they make it conversational they make it
you to be able to apply it to real world
stuff and that's what i i like about my
mom's using it right now to learn
italian oh really yeah she's loving it
that's so cool she's loving it yeah
there's somebody to be called talking
italian okay i will i'll test her out
you think i'm gonna test your mom and
don't tell me right now if she's not
doing well i'll tell your mother that
too all right okay i like it i like it
let's put the let's put the money where
the mouth is it's this woman there she's
who she is now because she's learning
italian
there's so many ways to learn with
babble in addition to lessons you can
access podcasts and games and videos and
stories and even live classes so of
course we have a deal for you right
right now our list is when you purchase
three months of babel uh subscription
you'll get an additional three months
free they double it buy three get three
free that's six months for the price of
three just go to babel.com and use promo
code tastebuds
with an s and that's babbel.com
code tastebuds for an extra three months
free
the regular pretzel dog is great the
tiny pretzel bites are great the
jalapeno cheese one and cheese one are
so gross can we just go to the pretzel
types pimp okay
can we scroll to the top i'll start from
the beginning listen to this you got
your original hot pretzel and by the way
this is also not the pretzel that you're
getting on the new york street it's not
the pretzel that you're getting at
yankee stadium they dip these pretzels
in butter
and i'm saying that as a plus it is you
when you get an alien pretzel they give
it to you like a little wax paper so you
don't you know your hands stay you smell
when you pass nanny ends in a mall it's
all better same thing with cinnabon but
that buttery that butter hot butter
if you're undeniable if you're saying
scent to scent cinnabun's got you beat
but i love your buttery smell banana
coconut butter is all i'm saying it's
original good pretzels cinnamon sugar
pretty good
pretty good like a churro meets a
pretzel pretty good but it lacks the
salt and it's it's a little bit of a
letdown people use that with the cream
with the cinnamon sugar you have a
cinnamon sugar with the dip it's
essentially like all the best parts of
the cinnabon but with a pretzel
sweet almond my favorite one my favorite
one
it is
unbelievable i dip it in the caramel it
has a crunch to it it's a buttery crunch
with caramel that doesn't sound good to
you keep going pimpy sour cream and
onions disgusting the savory in you
disgusting roasted garlic and parmesan
grosser not true pepperoni the grossest
pepperoni pretzel no way the grossest
chicken
with the cheese even grosser
than the pepperoni pretzel
and then finally just a lonely raisin
you argued for cinnamon raisin bagels i
love a cinnamon that's a soft pretzel
raisin in it
i would try it and i would even try the
honey almond or whatever the hell it was
called but those savory ones are
disgusting dude those are disgusting you
haven't had them don't you dare i never
would then
i would never eat a soft pretzel with
savory uh seeds how could you say it's
disgusting then because it doesn't sound
because it doesn't to me because it
looks disgusting to me you've got a
jalapeno you got a pretzel with what
looks like burnt crispy
jalapenos a cinnabon glued to cheese on
cinnabon it looks so gross about the
weight of a goddamn large grapefruit
it's just packed with goo now that's
good
and sugar now let's go down the menu
here let's get on the menu here you got
your classic rollover at cinnabun
unbelievable then you got your bond
bites so it's the same it's the exact
same thing smaller
yeah yeah for the people like you that
weenie complain that it's too big and
heavy there's a little dainty one you
can ask you
i just gave you
eight different pretzels and eight
different different dips babe we're two
comments into the menu we're two things
in the menu settle down now that's eight
to the eighth pound
now settle down we're going to go
through the menu you could have
legitimately you could probably have 64
different types of settle down now
caramel pecans 64 combinations caramel
pecan buns you ever have caramel pecan
cinnamon i have because caramel you
think is gross
no i said the caramel pretzel dip looked
gross about that you said uh caramel
pecan bond bites okay just a smaller
version center of the roll i mean just
genius because everybody's favorite part
of a cinnabon is the center of the roll
then they got sin of sweeties
then they got cinnamon sticks which
actually are churros unlike your pretzel
powdered and cinnamon that's whatever
they get a churro swirl
that is genius they took the churro and
they wrapped it into a donut shape it's
cheesy
let me tell you something about the
cinnabon then we got it nobody can
finish a cinnabon without getting a
stomachache that's nobody can finish the
cinnabon without like that is not true
that is
get a cinnabon true
initiative you feel like your life is
falling apart true or false no my left
doesn't feel like it's falling apart you
don't eat what do you say
and you get a charge from a honey almond
caramel
two pounds have a moist cleanse the size
of a softball it sits in your stomach
it's probably 2 400 calories get it out
of here you're nuts you don't walk
around the mall being like what am i
doing with my life you can't get one of
those to a kid a kid will jump off the
second floor of the mall post haste
you're not a kid you can't inject a kid
with a cinnabon
we've got to be 300 grams of sugar and
all the nutritional facts pimpy babe
i'll say it to you as i always say it to
you
a big more extravagant menu doesn't
impress me cinnabon keeps it simple
because all they need to do is keep it
simple okay they have such a strong
product that is it
yeah 880 calories 36 grams of fat 59
grams of sugar equivalent to 15
teaspoons of sugar you know what else
it's why it tastes awesome it is awesome
i'm not eating a cinnabon for lunch i'm
not dieting on cinnabons okay i'm having
a cinnabon once in a while it's an
amazing treat
by the time you come out of the other
end of that cinnabon tunnel though your
life is in shambles
the quote you're reading says it's like
eating a bowl of sugar all that sugar
will cause a spike in blood sugar and
then crash i'm not saying i'm completely
free of that with the auntie anne's but
just the density
give me the nutritional guide on that
auntie anne's jalapeno cheese pretzel
that abomination that exists on this
earth
oh boy oh boy wait wait wait can we get
okay this is how he spells danian's
cheat ah he just fixed it okay
so pepperoni pizza 480
pepperoni pizza no butter 440. like half
i love it
uh where is that where is that keep
scrolling well nothing's going to be 30.
not too bad
okay and the cheese and the cheese i
guarantee the cheese is at least another
150 at least no the cheese comes on it
now yes it does it's made with the
cheese
all right so yours is 880 that's 330.
yeah mine also tastes great and doesn't
make you have the liquid shits that a
cheese encrusted jalapeno annie anne's
pretzel would have i mean you i would
have to sit on the toilet as i ate it
dude
you talking about the cinnabon bro
doesn't have cheese on it you're right
yeah i started a cheese
i'm sure the side of cheese has its own
nutritional facts and i and i cop to
that my point though is that dude look
at this look at this garbage look at
this garbage they're telling you what to
pair it with like it's fine dining try
it with a mango lemonade mixer and hot
salsa cheese dip i'm sorry that they're
trying to stimulate crossover growth on
the menu disgusting you can't use it as
an argument my point here being cinnabon
large and wide isn't every once in a
while time treat it's in every once in a
while time food i only had one in my
life people have it on occasion here
there it's more like a bakery item i
know it's in a mall but even in a mall i
passed it my whole life and didn't get
it because at what point do i want to
put up to my face
a a goddamn monstrosity you cut out a
calorie monstrosity you cut it with a
fork and knife and you didn't know the
calories until just now i didn't know
that it was double
pimp hit me with a mini bun nutritional
value why because i want to know but you
could tell me the nutritional value of
one bite then of a cinnabon i don't need
it in its mini form a mini bun is is
quite satisfactory and satisfying a
pretzel people go to pretzels regular
pretzels daily so pretzels are already
ingratiated to people as an all the time
snack a hot pretzels
430
less than your precious
pretzels great right
so what was the point that you proved
that
my point is you don't have to get the
giant cinnabon if you don't want it you
can get a mini bun for 350 calories
great
now if you're gonna get extra frosting
like you said it needed like you said it
needed that's adding an extra 210. he
this is the guy that said it needed that
the giant cinnabon with this frosting
all over it wasn't enough frosting he
needed more once you penetrate the top
animal the middle gets dry and the
bottom is lights out dry
you need all the ice cream
once you eat about 30 of the cinnabon
you're left with no icing and the icing
is the star of the show with the
cinnamon by the way by the way good just
just a side note just a side note we
recorded today after hey babe okay we
record the name hey babe we were
supposed to start at 3 30
it got pushed till 4 30. because it got
pushed to 4 30 i hit rush hour traffic i
got here at five we're sitting here
doing this episode then i got to drive
home 45 to 55 minutes back and it just
started pouring rain
you stuck it to me so good today i hope
you're happy i hope you're happy with
how you stuck it to me oh yeah really
i'm just doing my i'm just thinking
about my dave matthews yeah yeah
oh you son of a [ __ ] today get a
cinnabon on your way home it'll take you
the whole ride to eat it please then you
can [ __ ] your pants as soon as you kick
open the door god damn i was going to go
get a whole thanks you hear it out there
i do yeah yeah you happy that's god
bowling oh my god listen look at those
things look at the churro challange
[Applause]
it's a cup of hot
it's a cup of hot chocolate with a
doughnut as a cover i respect whipped
cream on the doughnut with a churro
through the dough
i respect it so much dude they don't
give churros
ass over at
i stand by these guys dude you're in a
mall what are we talking about this is
what you do at a mall man you're like
everybody before everybody in the
boardroom at cinnabon is on an iv
oh
this episode has a peloton ad
[Laughter]
by the way all joe needs on his peloton
is a picture of a cinnabon that he has
to race toward like a carrot dangling in
front of him listen to me true or false
a cinnamon bun is uh is it is it not not
an everyday treat it's just not that's
like i said it's not a hot pretzel is
way more of a frequent go-to than a
cinnabon just by virtue of that fact i
think the masses are telling us that
that annie ends pretzels i think better
than arguably
i can hear the rain i mean it's just
pouring down
there's been there's been times where i
by the way an annie anne's pretzel it's
not gargantuan it's not it doesn't have
a lot of girth
no it's not it's it's very very
snackable it's very finishable uh you
don't feel like oh my god i can't move
there's been there's been times
pretzels finished my pretzel and also
still had more you're never going to do
that with a sinner cinnabon is like you
could do it it's been a while this is
cinnabon ready cinnabon is take this why
are you discounting the mini bun over
and over again
why don't what i'm taking why couldn't
it buy it at its flagship product you
can't you can't because i'm not taking
it in the ends of this flagship product
it's still pretzel no i'm saying but
you're discounting the fact first of all
aliens pretzels are huge
pimp pull up a picture of a hand holding
an auntie anne's pretzel they're big
dude that is not an easy walking easy
eating look at the size of that thing
are you nuts but it's thick that has to
you have to throw that up you have to
look himself you were out of your mind
look up what annie anne's is in grams
and look up what a cinnabon original is
in grams
by the way you're supposed to eat a
cinnabon whether it's i could throw a
cinnabon at you and it would i would be
taken to jail because it could be used
as a weapon
i could take somebody out with a with a
dense cinnabon there is no way in any
ants pretzel is only two ounces there's
no way do you understand when you hit
somebody in the face at a full baseball
throw with a cinnabon you could knock
their lights out cold
the ounces i'll just talk to i'll just
no i'm trying because pimp doesn't know
that it's weight in ounces and not grams
i really thought it was
it's
it is that
that's a cinnabon roll that is not
correct
just go to cinnabon nutrition facts
it'll be right on there in the serving
size
just go to cinnabon nutrition classic
roll
sit up on classic roll click on that
there's got to be just cinnabon
nutrition facts that's all we need
cinnabon nutrition facts 216. 268 grams
all right so what is that
it's like two pounds no it is not that
cinnabon does not waste two pimpy don't
268 grams convert to convert to ounces
it does not weigh two pounds
it's nine ounces nine and a half ounces
two pounds
268 grams now annie and pretzel
is two ounces it says i don't believe
that i think that's 123 grams it's half
the size okay
but that's still big
but but you're double big babe they have
the mini buns
how many times you have to stay here let
me explain to you what cinnabon is you
cut me off cinnamon is you haven't had
this in a real long time you've said i'm
here we dare you
and [ __ ] that
[Music]
eat this if you dare they it's almost
like a chef you dare you either you eat
a cinnabon until you eat are you going
to a mall and eating any eggs i never
i'm going to a mall once every three
four months ten years yeah but i'm
telling you i lived a long life before
that
i'm just saying i'm telling you right
now i think the challenge where they eat
the cinnabon is can you finish this
that's not the case
listen fine maybe it's not a challenge
and i can easily finish it but i'll tell
you this right you think i want the
items that's why i'm trying to shop for
deals i shop till i drop you you get a
bond you drop the beauty of [ __ ]
that's the beauty of cinnabon they're in
cahoots with the rest of them all
they're putting you into a state of
lethargy you don't know what's up or
down you're going into stores and buying
[ __ ] you don't need no i want to go
she gives me the right amount of
nutrition i need to keep a pep in my
step so i can go and spencer gifts and
buy a black lives i am giving
i am giving cinnabon credit for working
against the buyer in the mall and for
the proprietors i am giving them credit
for that no you go home after you eat a
cinnabon dude i don't you go home
i don't that's where you go oh oh i
gotta get home i'm dead tired and i
gotta literally i had to literally empty
my bowels ah
but i i will give you this uh annie's
pretzel is a lighter snack flavor-wise
if you get look i'll even give you
regular or cinnamon pretzel i'll give
you the two the two like sort of
landmark pretzels there okay i give it
to you it's a lighter snack but when you
talk pound for pound deliciousness you
can't
with a cinnabon with a goddamn soft
pretzel and i'm from philly and guess
what in philly the soft pretzels ain't
hot they're nice and cool they're room
temp okay you can have it any way you
like i can i guess just no you can't you
can't get a cold any ants it's hard you
can't do that people i like to do myself
a little bit of writing and when i'm
writing i like to save some time i like
to work more efficiently because it's
the little things that start adding up
and hogging up your day and the next
thing you know you're aggravated and
yelling at a computer screen that's
where grammarly premium came into my
life and fix stuff this is going to give
you real-time suggestions on your
writing so you can get to the next item
on your list in record time you can use
this to to to find uh clarity
suggestions for instance so you're using
the best language possible vocabulary
suggestions so you don't have to stop
and search for synonyms uh which i do
all the time i'm always looking at
thesaurus.com for stuff yeah my whole
thing is i want to write something i
want it to sound as as good as it could
possibly sound and it elevates
my
own the way i write in context my
vocabulary stuff like that i i threw it
on recently because i was i've been
writing decks for like pitches and stuff
like that and there's one thing that i
found that this actually helps me expand
my vocabulary because it gives you the
suggestion it's a word that i don't
often use i like to go right then and
there and look at the word and get an
essence of the word i used to read the
dictionary what about you
no i never did all right which is why i
like this app it makes me sound smarter
that's why i like the app too it's kind
of like it actually improves my own
vocabulary and it integrates seamlessly
into microsoft office or your internet
browser your phone and many many many
more places so here's the deal you're
gonna get 20 off when you go to
grammarly.com tastebuds that's
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash taste buds for 20
off grammarly.com taste buds to get your
deal today hit send with confidence to
get your point across more effectively
with grammarly premium get 20 percent
off grammarly premium by signing up at
grammarly
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y dot com slash taste
buds
uh i mix i match
i match i mix
but i like to mix more than i like to
match you must be a fan of fizzy i am i
like a good mix what am i getting hard
seltzer with antioxidants with
vitamin c also less than a gram of carbs
and about one gram of real cane sugar
per can i can live with this folks 100
cows 5
alcohol by volume which is stronger than
some beers i said this last time we
talked about fizzy the blueberry
watermelon flavor is knocking me
sideways that's part of their new
variety pack which has blueberry
watermelon kiwi watermelon passionfruit
watermelon and mango watermelon all are
delish but man i'm loving that blueberry
uh i gotta tell you vizzy is great you
can enjoy refreshments
and get antioxidants at the same time
what do you want five percent average
alcohol amount hundred calories per can
and once again one gram of real cane
sugar per can every sip of visi is more
exhilarating so so you're going to want
to try busy today and here's how you do
it you can purchase visi by going to
visiheartseltzer.com tastebuds that's
vizzyhardzeltzer.com
tastebuds and if you want to get updates
on the latest flavor drops and more sign
up for emails at busyheartseltzer.com
subscribe again that's
vizzyheartseltzer.com
subscribe and you must be 21.
you cannot get a cold annie anne's you
gotta eat that thing no they run it
through the thing you could tell them
that you just want it from behind the
thing without being heated up are you
insane good luck with that good luck
with that they're right there
don't run it tell me how it is when you
eat it cold eat it cold tell me about it
it's delicious my sister used to work
there and bring home the leftover stock
for the night and used to bring it home
see now we're getting to the bottom of
it he's got family involved in the
business i mean granted no joke this is
easily 20 years ago easily but she used
to come home with a bag of annie anne's
and it was just as good then it was it
was in the world one other thing i'd
like to tell you i've never i've never
seen that option i've never been offered
it cold i've only been well you need you
have to get uh
it works
and i like it can i say one other thing
go ahead the i like the breadth of
choice of flavor choice at any ants
you're not just getting they're not
building it on the standard salted
pretzel and that's it there's eight
options and dips for some 64 possible
flavor combinations with the cinnabon
yeah you got one you got one that throws
a pecan if you you go to berry and just
all you're doing
all the time you're in a mall it gets
old if you're in a mall and you go up to
us auntie anne's and say i would like
your sour cream and onion pretzel with
your jalapeno cheese dip you were there
to rob a gamestop you were there to do
something awful in that hole
no
sane person is getting that no way i i
it's the audacity to order something
like that in the middle of your day who
do you think you are i guarantee you
this how about this i think the only
people ordering cinnabon went to the
mole for a cinnabon
i think
for anything else is that a bad thing i
think they're going there getting a
cinnabon and leaving okay they're going
back and they're getting there in time
for the production crew of hoarders to
be at their house perfect terry perfect
mall day perfect mall day tell me i'll
please start at sam goody got the [ __ ]
up
into the arcade i'm going home
all right
you're out of your mind dude all right
let's go if i was that good i would have
had one in my life that's not true
you've never had a whopper and the
whopper is amazing you've never had one
you would have been for the first time
six months i've never been i've never
been like let me go to cinnabon and look
at their menu and order something
because you're dumb we've discussed
babe dumb or not babe i know i'm just
kidding you're not dumb i'm just joking
i thought pip would laugh when i called
you dumb and you did all right let's go
to the phones bub
cinnabon is the only legal
way to get creamy goodness at the mall
beautiful
you know who likes cinnamon bon christos
stefano annie anne's all the way
that's tough when you're using chris
against me in the argument
annie hans is the devil those pretzels
are a religious experience each and
every time i have to imagine it's a
similar feeling to the last supper but i
don't know for sure because i wasn't
there honestly thank you john millmore
cinnabon got it to trending look at this
no annie ann's is trending i lost if
annie hans is trending that i lost wow
yeah
guys we got annie it's trending baby i
love it
cinnabon is for people who want their
diabetes to have diabetes all right
that's in the lead that is our lead
comment so far the one this one's tough
both get you with the smell but at least
add to the pretzel i can still look my
wife in the eyes
there you go true you don't eat in a
mall but if i must choose a soft pretzel
is what came to mind when i read best
mall snack fatties cinnabon is nature's
sleeping pill these are weak weak
arguments pretzel maker puts annie ends
to shame i don't know pretzel maker
cinnabon it is joe's taste in food
versus joe's ability to put together a
clear argument to fit again
oh that is so great jordan
he might have won before i think i
recognized that name he's got like the
most gorgeous sports car on the road
doing its thing for joe's taste and food
and then his ability to put an argument
together is just an old pickup on the
side of the road a lot of people like my
arguments that's half a minivan yeah
that's very funny
uh that's very funny all right uh dr
caldera sends white mice to the cinnabon
in omaha to use his icing i don't know
what that means dr carl there is my
better call saul
ah
character i don't really quite get what
that means though still cinnabon is your
fur is the first girl you date in
college wild free reckless and always a
good time annie ends as the librarian
boring old and salty cinnabon for the
win nah that's great the pretzel just
hits different and you can make cinnamon
buns all the time and you can get
cinnamon pretzels anyway i agree we kind
of cover the cinnabon in our pretzel
menu how dare you sugar how dare you i
will not let you sit here and say that i
will not pass it here no it's got butter
cinnamon and icing the cinnabon cinnamon
spread on the inside that dark gooey
stuff there is nothing in anything yeah
but i'm saying we have the out there
no you don't no you don't yes we do
okay how dare you you take that back
both are pale comparisons to nathan's oh
nathan's fries
but this was not a savory
hardest one ever look at this wow
uh i hate cinnamon okay so that's you if
you vote any ends just block me now
all right we'll block you pretzels are
so much better cinnabon is for annoying
little children who are begging to go to
the lego store all right this is pretty
split down the middle pimpy let's give i
think the win is to people who want
their diabetes to have diabetes right i
like that we laughed very heartily at
that follow at narlord that's at
gnar underscore l-o-r-d
on twitter here
thanks for the winning tweet let's see
what we got pimp
whereas this is big this is big because
we are tight in this let's just talk
about that for a second we are very
close
in the win loss column right now like i
think it's like
you might be separated by a win or a
loss i think after last episode you're
up
no you're up two
i don't know we're close enough that
this win could make it
i think a big difference for either of
us yeah this is big i don't know what to
do here nine just about 10 000 votes
oh
pimp one cinnabon
yes
thank you god give me thank you god
67.80
32.2
where my annie and stands at and he
stands
give me a break
i stand ian
i'm a stantian
auntie anne's my stan
i stand her
i love annie ants
i'm going to go to any ends tonight
cinnabun sucks
i'll just keep saying fun stuff until
you talk
you gotta end the episode you won all
right i'm just saying basking in a
little bit yeah bask in it
let it rain a little harder before i
have to walk outside
well look guys we all knew aliens no i i
i'm really happy right now
shut up that's a couple of w's there
between last week and this week just
shut up
and i feel i feel like back to a little
bit of confidence you don't understand
guys you could lose your confidence
big with a couple of unanswered you know
the overall vote by the way was that it
should just be a straight up it's wins
takes the cake i understand i really got
bashful why don't we do a constellation
we'll make it its own separate entity
we'll make the winner of the season
record but we'll also have something
else as its own competition for
percentage gap but we won't use
percentage gap in relation to wins for
the season okay on the record you know
what i'm saying yes uh
check out the
tenderloins.com
tour for all the tour dates that are on
now uh they're on sale right now we're
going to like 50 cities uh starting
november 19th all through 22. if you
don't see your dates we'll be adding
them and go to savilecanoncomedy.com for
all my solo dates a bunch of them are on
sale right now
jonahro is a comedy on twitter and
instagram i'll be probably announcing
some dates soon but the more importantly
joey rose's brick and mortar bar and
sandwich up is coming very soon big
announcements and reveals coming up on
that thank you for listening everybody
thank you for subscribing keep spreading
the word we appreciate your support we
couldn't do this without you i still
love you love you too taste buds they
coming to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two foods gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man yeah
they're coming to them